welcome to the uplift get on in here we
have a great show for you today and a
great cast of characters a beluga whale
who befriended villagers on the coast of
Norway and became a member of their
community
a mother-daughter Duo who hiked for a
whopping six months and had a good
reason behind their Epic Journey a mom
who delivered a baby where
plus the people who jumped in to help
her when she went into labor in the
unexpected place and a popular YouTuber
who creates his wacky yet informative
videos in his secret lab
all that plus our heartwarming videos
you just need to see you are watching
The Uplift
[Music]
hey what's going on y'all I'm Nate
Burleson and this is the show that lifts
you up for at least the next 30 minutes
we begin all the way in Norway where a
whale has become part of the community
here's Caitlin O'Kane with more
in the small Arctic city of hammerfest
Norway you may have to get into a boat
to see the town's most iconic resident
the voldemir the Beluga the gentle giant
is not from Norway the townspeople
believe he once worked as a Russian spy
whale and then fled I always say it
sounds like something that like a comic
book artist ran out of ideas or
something in the 50s and created this he
was trained to do military spy work you
can send a whale a lot further and a lot
longer and a lot deeper than you can a
human first of all and second of all
that whale can go undetected
voldemir likely had cameras strapped to
him he boldly left his old life behind
showing up on the coast alone and in
need of help he has started pulling at
Fisherman's boats and buoys and
equipment and getting their attention
one of the fishermen in Norway
really realized something's wrong with
this picture there's a way of wearing a
harness he got in the water himself and
was able to undo the harness and take
Voldemort mirror out of the harness
which I think is really important an
important thing to have happen for
valdemir because I I don't think he
probably could have lived his whole life
and not too comfortably once freed
voldemir bonded with the town's people
the community came together to take care
of him raising money to feed him fish
and keeping an eye on him to make sure
he was safe
human friends voldemir lives a lonely
life as the only Beluga in the area so
filmmaker Regina Crosby is leading the
charge to help find a more sustainable
situation for him it's um it's an
ongoing situation he is
he is free but he is incredibly
vulnerable and so it's it's become much
more than a film for me I created a
non-profit for him called
onewail.org and that organization's only
objective in life is to protect him help
him survive and hopefully give him a
chance at a normal whale life
voldemere has already shown improvements
since coming to Norway it was believed
that he would never eat again on his own
and even the people who'd come from the
Captivity world that were feeding him
were shocked to learn that he swam off
and they were afraid that he was going
to starve then he has taught himself or
relearned his behavior to eat on his own
right now the Beluga lives at salmon
farms around hammerfest but it's not the
safest or most natural place for him to
live basically he only knows for the
most part life with humans so it seems
natural to him he he's so sweet and and
I I love that he's not alone because he
makes it very clear he doesn't want to
be alone Norway is vast there's plenty
of space if he wants to be alone he just
doesn't show any interest so what he is
interested in is humans and the ones
that are the most reliable are those
that work on the sea every day and
that's the salmon Farmers so he's
figured it out how to cope with the
situation the best that he can
um he thinks you know he thinks he's
helping them out he's there working on
time keeps a good schedule
still threats exist out in the ocean and
since voldemir isn't used to living in
the vast sea Regina's plan is to make a
500 acre Reserve right in Norway for him
to live in my dream is that we build the
reserve have this beautiful open space
where he can uh be free but also not
have the threats of propellers and
there's no way for tourists to just have
free game at him and then that we have
more belugas come into the reserve and
that he teams up and makes a little pot
once valdemir learns how to live in The
Reserve he'll hopefully be ready to
transition into the ocean no longer just
one whale but one of many all of the
researchers and whale experts I've
spoken with they agree that the more
whales the better so a pair of whales
who are released to the wild it's
actually a greater success rate than if
it was just one whale released to a wild
he'll have to leave behind the human
friends who took care of him all these
years but with with him he'll take their
love in lessons and he'll finally truly
be free
see that's a well of a story you just
had to see to believe it love that
coming up meet a woman who gave birth in
an unexpected place
[Music]
my water broke um
scary definitely expected to be in the
hospital
you gotta find out where she welcomed
her bundle of joy after the break plus
our heartwarming videos you just need to
see don't you go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift we now have
the heartwarming videos you just need to
see starting with this one a mom named
Felicia was posing for a photo in London
when this happened
[Music]
that is her son Peter who decided to
surprise her with a photobomb mom was
visiting from Ghana and hadn't seen her
son in 10 years her daughter helped
arrange Peter surprised when she got to
London she didn't even have to see his
face she recognized his hand on her
shoulder that's a mama's love right
there all right now take a look at this
next video that shows a three-year-old
who has Santa all figured out
[Music]
oh I wanted this from targets
wait did Canada go to Target
I want to take a mattress
okay
[Music]
he saw all over it she's like wait a
minute wait a minute so there's no elves
Santa's just picking up stuff at Target
all right now if that last video didn't
convince you that you never can predict
what a kid is going to say how about
this video of a three-year-old named
Hazel
if you could say one bad word
without getting in trouble what would it
be
I want to see a nice word baby shark
okay
I like that choice
baby shark Hazel well Hazel you know a
setup when you see one that was a setup
and you played it right
coming up meet the mother and daughter
who went on an epic hike to raise money
for a cause that's close to their hearts
and we're not talking about a one day
hike we're talking six months on the
trail
we talk about that all the time that how
do you grasp like how far we walked like
it's hard to comprehend that we walked 2
200 miles
and a woman who gave birth in an
unexpected Place Plus the heroes who
sprang into action to help
[Music]
we now introduce you to a woman who gave
birth in an unexpected place but
fortunately nearby Heroes rushed to her
side here's Scott McFarland with the
story
Christina Hansen's baby daughter Quinn
enjoys the long walks in the stroller
the sidewalk outside the U.S Capitol we
caught up with mom in her new arrival
Washington they weren't just visiting
here we've got some Smiles now
we needed this fresh air Quinn was born
right here Hanson a Washington D.C
Elementary School teacher went into
labor one morning this fall and by her
own admission waited a little too long
to head to the hospital
barely into the drive she knew she
wouldn't get there her head was coming
out my my water broke on the way in the
car Hanson's mom was driving and stopped
outside the U.S Senate after spotting
Capitol police officers then waved them
over for help is that scary
it's definitely scary definitely
expected to be in the hospital
to deliver Quinn Captain carnisha
Mendoza who works in the agency's Civil
disturbance unit ended up being one of
two Capitol Police on the front lines of
this beautifully civil disturbance point
I started talking to her and she told me
her water broke and then she said the
head was coming out so I mean I when
people say um good job congratulations
on delivering the baby I say you know
the baby really delivered herself K-9
inspector Jackie yanika 14 years on the
job and herself a mom coached and calmed
Hansen and helped a medic cut the
umbilical cord that's probably one of
the best things they've done in my
career which was not expected whatsoever
but a pleasant surprise for the U.S
Capitol staff and Community which last
year saw such ugliness and despair first
Christmas Baby Quinn brings Joy the
officers give gifts and regularly ask
for photos and mom has a new favorite
landmark around which to walk that
stroller you forever have a story oh
forever forever a story to tell about
how this beautiful little girl came into
this world at 11 54 A.M
on Constitution Avenue in our nation's
capital
already making her own history
not all heroes wear capes or hospital
scrubs all right we now have an
awe-inspiring story about a
mother-daughter Duo who went on a hike
together and if you're wondering how
that's outstanding just know that it
wasn't any hike they walked for six
months through about a dozen states here
CBS Minnesota's Susan Elizabeth
Littlefield with more
glad to have you back you did it
we did
because it's almost
unimaginable minnesotans Sue and Greta
hiked from Maine to Georgia up to 30
miles per day we talk about that all the
time that how do you grasp like how far
we walked like it's hard to comprehend
that we walked 2 200 miles a journey a
mission they've been raising seventy
thousand dollars for Parkinson's
research in honor of their husband and
father who's on a journey of his own to
fight the disease does it make you think
of Parkinson's on even a deeper level
yeah it's a it's a great parallel and a
great analogy Parkinson there's a lot of
obstacles in your way you know mental
and physical mental health yeah right
Sue knows firsthand she had two major
obstacles herself after falling in
Pennsylvania uh nine stitches here 10
Staples you know
um at the top of my head so we bought
the helmet so they marched on a feat so
taxing they each lost 50 15 pounds in
the first two weeks I'm guessing you
were pretty hungry we were literally
starving
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we burned on
average five thousand there was I think
a 7 000 calorie day so Trail Angels
became their Saving Grace I tallied it
up the day after we finished and we
stayed in the homes of 25 different
families who we had never met before
meeting them and their stories are just
so powerful that was by far the best
part of the trail and the most
surprising we didn't even know what a
trail Angel was before we went on the
trail as the Angels laid watch they hit
the finish in Georgia four days before
Christmas greeted by friends and The Man
Behind the mission
it so was about the people and the
kindness and the goodness and support
and positivity is so alive and well in
humanity people say if you want to
restore your faith in humanity go hike
the Appalachian Trail and boy oh boy is
that true it's so true people are
amazing they sure are
all right here's a confession
I don't hike
I've never been hiking but if you send
me a team Fox shirt I will hike on
behalf of the cause all right coming up
meet a wildly popular YouTuber who
cranks out content and is Willy Wonka
style Factory get an inside look on how
he makes science fun for everyone
[Music]
Mark Robert has gained 23 million
YouTube subscribers by making science
fun Jamie wax visited Robert's secret
lab in California where the magic
happens
let's join him and watch Mr Wizard
oh hi
wizard oh hi Rita come on
[Music]
multiple Generations have gained an
interest
in science and technology from
entertaining experts so I understand
we're ending with a bang yes
performing fun experiments and so now in
our case instead of pumping we fill this
tank up with high pressure nitrogen gas
for today's audience
Mark Rober has taken that concept over
the top I think you are the new
incarnation of something that has been
going on a long time you teach facts in
a very fun way yeah I like to hide the
vegetables right like get kids stoked
about science and education and
Engineering without realizing that's
what's happening
I bring you in with you know world's
largest jello pool and it's a banger
thumbnail and it's like what a 15 ton
jello pool
before you know it you're learning about
chemistry and the scientific method and
how he came to this
and it's not just kids who become
obsessed with his work the biggest
compliment I can get is when like a
family says like the parents are like I
love your videos my kids also love your
videos right so could it be like this
Pixar thing where it's like it kind of
works on on many different levels Rover
worked at Nasa for 10 years then Apple
for five
oh
the precious heck but when he got to 10
million followers he followed his heart
and his opportunities and changed
direction to be fair I was making more
money off YouTube than I was at Apple
for a few years but then I was like you
know what I just need to do this thing
full time so basically a white shirt cut
a hole in the front
cut a hole in the back I had like a
video about a decade ago a Halloween
costume or an iPad in front an iPad and
back you do a FaceTime video chat it
looks like you have a hole in your body
and I uploaded it to YouTube and the
next day it had like a million and a
half views it's like on the front page
of these websites and I was like well
this is a cool feeling because I have
more ideas his sense of being rewarded
for Creative Innovation began while
growing up as a quiet and introverted
child who didn't speak until he was four
years old in third grade we got the
standardized test back and you know I
did pretty well on them and my mom saw
the scores and she was like oh I'm so
sorry but there's a mistake here this is
definitely not my son right it always
used to be like plug in mark this is
like what they'd say because I I lacked
a certain amount of common sense but he
didn't lack creative sense it was when
he was a kid that he came up with his
first hack I was like five years six
years old and my mom asked to help with
dinner and so so you know she had me
cutting onions so I went upstairs and
got some swim goggles and now this is
like understood as a life hack but I was
like a five-year-old and there was no
BuzzFeed back then to get these hacks on
right that made such an impact on her
and I remember her laughing and just
thinking it was super clever his mother
passed away from ALS just six months
before he posted his first video it's
this really interesting thing where it's
like you don't know the full measure of
your impact even why you're here you
know what I mean like she was the
biggest influence on My Life by a
comfortable margin welcome
the secret entrance the idea is you come
in here and you don't know that there's
a super high-tech lab behind this
bookshelf so here we come where Theory
becomes practice this is a spot yeah
this is kind of the Arena so we we build
it in the other room and then we can
bring it in here to test it we visited
him at crunch Labs his testing space
slash Studio outside San Francisco and
then
I was able to see and even try out a few
of his most famous Creations here we go
yes that was amazing I have to ask you
how much danger are you actually in in
these experiments I really do try and
bring the viewer along for the ride and
we don't know what will happen when we
go out and do these things so here's our
first test shot I want to be careful and
not make kids think it's okay to take
risks
many of his proudest accomplishments
have taken place outside the lab
like declaring war on the thieving
squirrels in his backyard and so I was
like well I'm a NASA engineer I can
protect my bird seed against these
squirrels who became Like a Man versus
squirrel thing an obstacle course and
declaring war on thieving scam call
centers they do about 20 million dollars
a year and we basically used engineering
to come up with like smoke bombs you
know obviously glitter bombs we had this
one time delay lunch box and like 100
cockroaches came out of course we hacked
their CCTV so we could watch the whole
thing unfold real time
[Music]
the point is I made a story and I
brought you along for the ride so that
people would share this video and here
it is my goal with crunch Labs is to
help you think like an engineer his
latest passion is called the crunch Labs
build box a challenging educational toy
that's delivered monthly so in this one
we learn all about flywheels and sort of
the Quan effect and how frisbees fly
yeah
wow look at this
so it's one thing to passively watch a
video but to get there and to be
building like alongside me as I show you
how to put it together and then teach
you how it works and so I love this idea
of just making it so accessible that you
know hopefully anyone can put themselves
in my shoes and think you know this is a
cool thing I could do this I could see
myself as that as an engineer this you
might recognize yes this is where it all
started and all of this has led Mark
Rober to his biggest and most rewarding
engineering project yet his remarkable
life in using the power of pneumatics
you just step off oh my gosh could you
have imagined this life for you no and
it's so ridiculous but do I know where
I'll be 10 years from now absolutely not
but what I can promise you is I'm gonna
keep trying my hardest on every single
Rock I'm on and then just see where the
path leads
it's like one of my favorite shows
Dexter's Laboratory see having a
laboratory can be fun all right that's
our show I hope this news brightened up
your day and lifted you wow that's what
we like to do around here have a good
one be nice to people